duo of the year congratulations thank
you so much this is awesome
so it's amazing it's awesome this is so
cool it's so amazing so awesome have you
had a chance to call justin bieber
congrats him just yet what are you
making of this celebration
i'm like in shock right now it was the
first the word of the night and i was
just like
i'm scrambled right now so i'm like
trying to process it all it's incredible
we're so grateful
especially this year it's been like a
bit of a different year we've been at
home
we haven't been able to you know feel
the love we haven't been able to you
know stand on stage and
feel that connection with the fans so
this is uh you know in a small way we're
able to connect with the fans
this is because of the fans so yeah
we're just we're so grateful
so good how do you guys follow it up
from here what a collaboration you
are you have with collab with next guys
oh my god it's a lot of pressure you
know with having the success
of that song and just all that's
happened you know obviously there's been
a lot of craziness that's happened in
the last year but you know a lot of
great things happened that we never
really
truly got to celebrate and now that
things are kind of picking back up it's
uh it's gonna be nice to
be able to maybe celebrate with him uh
you know in the hopefully not so distant
future but yeah we're just very thankful
to be here and always
to be here we're at the grand ole opry
with so much history even in this room
there's so many pictures on the wall of
just
legends and people that we look up to
and people that went before us so
we're just thankful to be here and uh in
the conversation and be here in the home
of country music
well look at you guys cementing
yourselves in your history
in country music's history right there
at the opry happy birthday to abby
unbelie like of all days i know right
it's a great birthday present yeah